[Musique]
entre nous
le rallye est dans leur sang l'an ii
pour ça
vva
la marseillaise sur un air de reggae en
mars 1979
serge gainsbourg beezik l'hymne national
le titre aux armes et caetera est
enregistré en quelques jours seulement
jamaïque en france la chance on va vite
devenir un scandale national
serge gainsbourg la marseillaise en
reggae c'est pas un peu de la
provocation
je pense pas je pense que le ring est
une logique révolutionnaire lammer cia
gic une un chant révolutionnaire la
chanson divise une partie de la classe
conservatrice s'indignent les militaires
aussi même au sein du gouvernement le
titre fait débat pour eux il est
interdit de toucher à la marseillaise
symboles de la nation monsieur musique
la marseillaise de gainsbourg
manifestement ça ne vous plaît pas pas
plus qu aux anciens combattants bien
entendu nous pouvons être qu'indigné
d'une telle interprétation
les critiques se multiplient l'écrivain
et résistant michel droit qualifie le
morceau d'odieux chienlit dans la presse
le 4 janvier 1980 à strasbourg la
polémique atteint son paroxysme visé par
une alerte à la bombe
gainsbourg décide d'annuler son concert
n'est pas sans un dernier pied de nez
suis un insoumis
et qui est redonnée à la marseillaise
son sens initial dans la salle des
militaires l'attend de pied ferme
face à eux bien ce bourg entame la
marseillaise le poing levé et a capella
[Musique]
marchons qu'un sang
14 décembre 1981
ultime provocation de gainsbourg lors
d'une vente aux enchères à versailles il
s'offre un manuscrit original de la
marseillaise
écrit par le poète rouget de lisle prix
de l'acquisition 135 mille francs vous
avez envie envie de vous venger des
parachutistes 80 vous avez ennuyer avec
la marseillaise que vous chantiez argué
n'ont cessé au garde à vous devant vous
un bon c'est pas cette version là que
j'avais non aux armes etc est devenu le
premier disque d'or de gainsbourg
plus de trois cent mille albums ont été
vendus en quelques semaines
[Musique]